we'll get five suggestions i feel it
should be good let's come to this wedge
here what would you like a wrap about
a bar
not being able to find the exit in a bar
cool okay cool i like it let's come to
um this segment over here catch you out
because you thought you had thinking
time what would you like a rap about
a doctor dealing with covert and what
did you say
uncircumcised penises
i um obviously i am uncircumcised
because
in my country we don't mutilate children
look
i know it's like a religious thing but
in like america it's just a thing and i
asked my friends i was like why did they
do that they were like we don't know
and i was like i think you should know
so i i did some research i found out
actually there is quite a good reason
for it what they do is they take all the
foreskins and they knit them together
and they make a senate minority leader
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so a doctor dealing with covert and
uncircumcised penises i'm gonna i'm
gonna combine those um and not finding
the excellent bar okay let's go back at
the room people right at the back i
wanna hear from you
what was the first
israeli policy one second one second no
well no people suggest that all the
[ __ ] time because they think they're
edgy you know someone said
you said something that ended in
republicans what was the first part
climate change republicans
with republicans okay cool some real
word soup there okay middle of the
middle of the room
ramadan ramadan is the the muslim period
of fasting before the celebration of eid
is that right yeah cool okay
and then people in the middle yes you've
got a hand up that's so polite i love it
if rappers be like put your hands up
you're like yes finally the opportunity
yeah
so just to recap what we've got not
finding the exit in a bar a doctor
dealing with covert and an uncircumcised
penis ramadan um and uh the what was
yours again
oh yeah republican climate change yes
what would you like a wrap about
the coolest dance move oh that's just a
question
um well there's not a i'll show you my
coolest dance move is no it's yeah
that's so you forgot what i was talking
about well that's fine um i will show
you i do one dance move uh it's that one
right
which is called the gwyneth paltrow at
the end of seven
um
[Music]
let's get a suggestion because that's
just you know i'm just [ __ ] knocking
out the part with these ad-lib jokes um
suggestion from the front
what was it
legalizing strippers i don't know what
state you're from but i'm pretty sure
okay
the one mormon in the room okay
[Applause]
so
not being able to find the exit in a bar
a doctor dealing with covert and
uncircumcised penis
climate change republicans ramadan and
legalizing strippers this uh lovely
people it's a freestyle that's a wrap
made up on the spot and we are lucky
enough to have some fantastic bands who
are gonna lay down some uh funky grooves
for us
and um i'm excited to see where this is
gonna go
and i'm sure you guys are intrigued as
well because this sounds like we're
about to start a set of
jazz lounge standards which uh
yeah this is the type of energy vibe i'm
feeling
where are we
gonna start let's this was a kind of
complicated mouthful so let's let's do
this nice
[Music]
pick your jaw up off your floor by the
time that you have seen this i walk in
whipping off the mask and pulling out my
penis the doctor sitting there in his
armchair saying chris i would see what
you got there it's like a little
windbreaker a hood upon your bell and
bring it in yeah i know it doesn't smell
cause i wash it every day rolling back
the turtle neck why cause i worry that
the doctor's gonna inspect my
little hole i like doc please i keep it
ever so clean there's never that cheese
clogging up around the side and the
worry that i got is that i've got this
slight tickle in my chest and cough and
he says yo chris i know it's kind of odd
but it's my job so i give the nasal swab
he puts it nozopharangeal the technical
name if you don't respect your doctor
it's a shame i'm putting all the blame
on the alcohol the blame on the drink
unstabilize your mind so it's difficult
to think you'd be walking round blurry
cross i can't check it you're like yo
dude how the [ __ ] i find that exit like
sean william scott and dude where's my
car it's pretty simple illuminated in
the bar the signs right there i know
it's kind of far kind of hard what
that's like 25 yards still you should
see but you're like it's not right i'm
confused why cause the show's so many
lies just ask somebody to bring you and
do a job or next time you come out maybe
get a service dog like a guide for the
blind yeah you're instructing him pull
him over here but like an angry
republican he doesn't want to budge
doesn't want to be bipartisan on
anything with cc that's the climate
change not the email below two whole
worlds on fire what you gonna do we're
just gonna hit sit here and get angry
why because joe manchin don't understand
me i know he's not a republican but
basically your name yeah a real democrat
but always gets the blame he's in west
virginia he needs to plump with the
biden side but mitch mcconnell's like
nah i'm like i inside i never budge i
never even say if you're doing ramadan
can't eat for the day when the sun rises
you really know your order not mouth and
morsel and not sip the water you gotta
wait until it goes down below caressing
on the horizon then it's time to blow
you'll be going back there maybe get a
nice bit of lamb having fun yeah respect
the ramadan i never did myself why cause
i'm atheist you were like a dance move i
was like sup chris time to pull out an
old joke about the movie seven the last
thing we're gonna do slightly unpleasant
if you can't get your eyes aroused and
you see all the ladies gyrating dropping
trout for me or even guys i don't mind
if they're male or the ladies legalizing
strippers yo guys are you crazy where
are they illegal where can't they be
maybe you not visited the netherlands
overseas you can walk through the red
light district they'll do more than
strip they will suck your dick unless
you've got a foreskin in which case
they're slightly put off they're like no
chris please you should run away cause
we don't like it we like it with the top
off there's a freestyle rap like we
knocked the [ __ ] block off
[Music]
you